[Music]
the last time we spoke we were talking
about your recovery from your injury my
goodness yeah nor money how is she doing
as far as I can tell no money's doing
great she's a really tough girl and I
listen it's not easy to get to the end
of the season injuries happen with a lot
of us have been there but gosh she's
such an amazing performer you would
never know that she's struggling with
any amount of pain and I commend her for
getting out there and doing it she's all
good to go for the final hopefully I'm
kinda out of touch with the three
finalists right now they are in that
studio rehearsing and just doing
everything that they can but from what I
see she's doing incredible normanni will
you go on a date with me now have Bonner
and Armani gone out a date yet and do
you approve have you given your approval
if I approve if that's what they want to
do I think that's so much fun I don't
know I haven't actually spoken to Bona
since were eliminated but cut off so
maybe he has gone out a lot applying
water yeah maybe he went out on that day